voilà j'ai extrêmement intéressant c'est
le sujet de sony sur le xperia juan
marque tout marque de numéro deux
experts il ya 1 2 enfin vous le
prononcer comme vous voulez toujours est
il que de ce nouveau sony xperia et fait
beaucoup de promesses s'adresse à une
cible qui est extrêmement large et
vraiment boosté d'un côté spécifications
techniques du côté fiche technique
à tel point qu'il est légitime de se
demander est ce que ce sont les xperia
one marque tous n'en fait pas un petit
peu trop
on va donc regarder ça aujourd'hui on va
faire un tour complet de la question que
ce soit au niveau de l'écran niveau de
l'audio au niveau de la performance au
niveau de l'autonomie au niveau de la
photo au niveau de la vidéo au niveau de
tous et croyez moi
croyez moi il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire mais juste avant si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas vous invite à dire vous
abonner pourquoi parce que je vous parle
effectivement vous voyez de smartphones
et de nouveauté dans ce cas-là de
smartphones que vous ne pouvez pas
beaucoup en test sur youtube
francophonie malheureusement pour eux on
parle ici on parle bien évidemment de
montres par l'ordinateur on parle de
vous de votre vie numérique
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre vie
numérique qu'est ce qui est bien qu est
ce qui est moins bien qu'est ce qu'on
peut améliorer et de plein de choses
bien évidemment toujours lié à boudry
numérique dont je vous invite à cliquer
sur le petit bouton que vous avez juste
en dessous ici le petit bouton rouge une
tête un petit clic vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié dès
qu'une nouvelle vidéo sortira et vous ne
manquerez absolument rien petite pause
c'est toujours une vidéo qui réalisé en
partenariat avec ali tools et oui même
pendant les vacances je suis là je fais
un petit break je fais des vidéos jolie
tourne je les montre comme ça c'est
pratique c'est bien et on découvre plein
de nouvelles choses allaient tous c'est
quoi c'est une extension web que vous
pouvez utiliser dans votre navigateur
google chrome firefox et elle vous
permettra de connaître plein de choses
pour vos achats sur un lit express ça se
présente comme sa vous cliquez vous
l'installer gratuitement lorsque vous
arrivez sur ali express et que vous avez
installé votre application vous avez ce
petit truc en bas ici qui est installé
nous allons pouvoir trouver pas mal
d'informations
regardez par exemple ici savoir un
historique une courbe de la fluctuation
des taxes vous permet de voir à quel
moment le produit est un peu moins cher
et lorsqu'il vous avez un pic comme ça
il vous est beaucoup plus haut que le
prix auquel a été proposé bien pouvait
venir
contacté le vendeur pour avoir une
remise et payer un peu moins
alors là j'ai une histoire il sort trois
mois je peux l'avoir sur six mois si je
veux voyez par exemple genre ya quelques
mois c'était beaucoup moins cher j'ai
ensuite des informations sur le vendeur
par exemple ici j'ai à faire un vendeur
qui a une note qui est élevé de 95%
produits de marques fiables en vente le
vendeur est présent sur le site depuis
plus de trois ans
voyons ça permet vraiment d'être
rassurés par rapport aux achats que vous
allez venir faire j'ai ensuite des
revues sont des photos que les clients
ont fait lorsqu'ils ont reçu le produit
chez eux
il ya vraiment un côté ration quand on
veut acheter un produit et puis ensuite
pu trouver des produits similaires à
celui là c'est par exemple lui elle ne
suffit pas ou ne me convient pas c'est
une solution qui est intéressante pour
toutes les personnes qui souhaitent
faire des achats sur ali express nous a
mis un lien en bas dans la description
pour venir le télécharger pour l'essayer
aller faire un petit tour vous allez
voir pour vos achats sur rail express
c'est une bonne solution et maintenant
retombe découvrir notre sony xperia one
mc2a presse qu'elle 1200 euros font de
faire quelque chose sur cette boîte
petite boîte blanche alors effectivement
réelle élégance mais on pourrait
s'attendre à voir un truc le plus
spectaculaire un truc un peu plus sexy
au niveau de la boîte en termes d'hommes
boxing en terme d'expérience quand on
met beaucoup d'argent dans son
smartphone n'a envie d'un peu autre
chose que du monochrome et là je suis
vraiment dans le monochrome ça c'est pas
extrêmement grave
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir un
très bon smartphone est ici on a un truc
est vraiment cool une proposition qui
est tellement intéressante que je me
vois dedans regarder la transparence du
truc
on a un smartphone qui est très long
tout ça pour avoir un écran avec un
format 21/9 est ce qui lui confère une
excellente prise en main pour négative
maintenant de ce smartphone c'est que
comme vous le voyez on a un don en verre
et ici on attrape très facilement les
traces de doigts au delà de ça il
faudrait passer un peu sur le côté
esthétique et côté un peu ménagée bien
en un smartphone qui est élégant qui est
beau qui est bien design et sony n'a pas
révolutionné son design et a gardé une
bord sur l'eau qui vient intégrer sa
caméra une bordure sur le bas même si
effectivement le fond d'écran voyez est
tout de suite un peu plus foncée pour
avoir un bouton pour monter baisser le
volume
un bouton pour l'allumer pour l'un qui
fait office de capteur d'empreintes
digitales et qu'il est verrouillé
extrêmement rapidement mais surtout un
bouton ici qui vous servira pour une
affaire de la photo et pour me refaire
votre mise au point de l'autre côté on
vient trouver son tiroir de cartes sim
vous avez besoin d' absolument rien pour
vous
ouvrir vous venez glisser votre doigt
vous le tir et vous mettez une cata
nothin plus une carte microsd pour
augmenter votre stockage jusqu'à intérêt
pour 1 kg est aussi très intéressant
pour trouver ici une prise jack
ça c'est extrêmement cool de la recharge
en usb ses smartphones qui est pas très
lourd 181 g plutôt plaisant à tenir au
moins ça s'est vraiment bien vous allez
en plus à un corning gorilla glass 6 qui
vient le protégez vous avez une
certification qui paie 65 ip68 résistant
à l'eau et à la poussière
en l'état actuel moi je le trouve plutôt
bien après c'est vraiment une question
de goût d'ailleurs dit man vous dès
maintenant ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce design
est ce que vous aimez le design que nous
propose sony sur le xperia one marque
tout c'est un manque un petit peu
rallongé
est ce que vous regrettez ces bordures
là au contraire est-ce que vous les
aimez
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
propositions est ce qu'elle est
différente de ce qu'elle est
intéressante et est ce qu'elle peut vous
tentez marqué le mois dès maintenant
bien évidemment on va en commentaire
pour son nouveau smartphone sony
s'adresse à beaucoup de cibles à
commencer par les cinéphiles les
personnes qui veulent profiter d'une
bonne expérience multimédia pour dire
regardez leur contenu pour vous proposer
quelque chose de vraiment top
ils ont dû mettre un écran de 6,5 pouces
un écran quand même suffisamment quand
un écran oled 4 qui à 3840 par 1644 à 4
128 pixels par pouces un écran hd air
donc ça c'est cool c'est la promesse qui
est fait et c'est très très bien sauf
que en fait ce qu'il faut savoir là
dessus c'est qu'un switch intelligent
qui va se faire au niveau de vos
smartphones donc si vous avez
effectivement du contenu 4k hdr et bien
vous allez pouvoir voir du contenu 4k
hdr imaginons par exemple sur netflix
vous allez regarder du contenu full hd
et bien votre smartphone vous afficher
du contenu full hd en 2560 1440 manière
lorsque vous allez jouer à des jeux vous
n'aurez pas du 4k de la même manière à
ce que vous aller naviguer sur internet
vous n'allez pas avoir de la 4k et ça il
faut le savoir à côté de ça lorsque vous
allez dans l'affichage vous allez
pouvoir venir avoir quelques petits
réglages en termes de qualité déjà vous
avez deux modes de modes différents
le premier mode c'est un mode standard
mode un petit peu classique vous allez
retrouver l'équivalent d'un écran bravia
c'est un peu l'idée en tout cas la
promesse qui nous est fait vous avez le
processeur x1 pour mobile qui va vous
permettre d'améliorer les vidéos mais
vous avez également un deuxième mode qui
est le mode créateurs qui va venir
changer le profil colorimétrique l'idée
du mode créateur c'est qu'il optimisé
par ciné alta est inspiré par la
reproduction des couleurs des moniteurs
100% des cyp3a vous de voir ce que vous
allez préférer personnellement
journée sur le mode standard qui ça
m'irait très bien si par contre vous
avez un côté qu'un petit peu bleuté
pouvait venir changer vous allez dans la
balance des blancs vous mettez en
réglage manuel et pourrait venir le
mettre en couleur moyenne samir le
réchauffer un peu chaud ça tire quand
même sur un espèce de jeunes a plus qu'à
cliquer pas terrible vous mettez sur
moyen et ça ira tout de suite beaucoup
mieux alors que les flaques qui vous
proposent des taux de rafraîchissement
qui sont beaucoup plus élevées à minima
90 voire 120 hertz pour certains et bien
ici vous n'avez que du 60 hertz est une
fois de plus pour un smartphone qui
coûtent quasiment 1200 euros et ça c'est
un peu dommage ça c'est un chant qui est
surprenant surtout quand on sait que
sony est un peu à la traîne je dire dans
la difficulté par rapport aux
smartphones par rapport à la concurrence
si je vous prends par exemple nos peaux
find x2 pro vous avez du quad hd vous
avez un écran 120 hertz et on est dans
les mêmes budgets on est dans les mêmes
tarifs donc pourquoi est ce que sony n'a
pas fait le choix en tout cas d'aller là
dessus même si on peut imaginer un
switch intelligente entre le 120ème 90
heures 60 hertz qui permettent
d'économiser la batterie comme on le
retrouve en tout cas chez beaucoup de
concurrents pourquoi est ce que une fois
de plus sur un budget de 1199 euros
eh bien vous avez uniquement du 60 hertz
voilà maintenant il ya aussi quelque
chose qui est un peu dommage
lorsque vous avez venir regarder du
contenu sur youtube c'est que vous allez
vous retrouver sur un format 18 ne
devienne encore plus sur un format 16
9ème commis si vous avez des grandes
bandes noires sur le côté et si vous
voulez qu'elle disparaisse autres vous
venez cros paix mais vous croquez
sauvagement vous trompez pas un petit
peu vous tromper beaucoup de tabous dans
l'est quand même une grosse partie de
l'image supérieur et de l'image
inférieur ça vaut pour youtube mais ça
donne également pour netflix
effectivement il ya du contenu qui
existent en 21 9e mais il ya très très
peu
et une fois de plus vous allez venir
croquer sauvagement dans l'image
on risque de couper quelques têtes ou
quelques jambes et ça c'est un peu
dommage à à l'enjeu c'est le format 21/9
c'est le format cinémascope ces formats
cinéma on rentre dans l'idée du cinéma
les jeux revient une fois de plus à nos
usages à nous et sony est pas le seul à
faire ça on retrouve beaucoup de
sortants avec des écrans vingt neuvième
21/9 vous avez des smartphones qui sont
de plus en plus allongée et les contenus
ne sont pas aujourd'hui pour la majorité
en 21 9ème pour les cinéphiles ont
effectivement expérience vidéo qui est
importante mais il ya également
l'expérience audio et là on se rapproche
de la deuxième cible qui sont les
audiophiles alors souvent les cinéphiles
vont avec les audiophiles
mais vous avez également les audiophiles
pur et dur qui ne volent pas d'image
tuées uniquement
tu es de la musique et ça c'est
intéressant alors ce qu'ils écoutent sur
ce smartphone c'est que vous avez des
hauts parleurs en façade juste ici au
dessus et qui est plus difficile à voir
qui est planqué là en dessous on n'a pas
un haut-parleur qui part comme ça ils
parlent vraiment en façade qui fait que
vous êtes plus dangereuse une notion
d'immersion alors que vous allez venir
regarder du contenu multimédia lorsque
vous allez jouer un jeu lorsque vous
allez regarder un film une série
regardez monsieur contre youtube ou que
sais-je encore donc ça c'est bien c'est
le premier point maintenant cette
expérience elle a aussi une certaine
limite on va pas avoir la meilleure
qualité et une fois de plus meilleure
qualité sur smartphone on reste sur nos
peurs du smartphone on va pas s'attendre
à voir un truc de dingue mais par
rapport à son corps trouvés notamment
sur un milices pro 2 xiaomi on a un
meilleur spectre une meilleure
spatialisation est ici c'est un petit
peu moins ça alors ça est difficile de
se rendre compte comme ça mais c'est
pourtant d un peu l'idée le son est pas
mauvais en lui même on n'est pas loin de
la meilleure expérience mais on n'y est
pas mais on n'est pas loin on n'est
vraiment pas loin je crache pas dans la
soupe
le deuxième point qui est aussi vraiment
intéressant c'est le fait d'avoir
effectivement cette petite prise jack
qui arrivent ici vous savez sur le
premium les prises jack disparaissent au
profit les casques bluetooth est ici
vous avez les deux ça c'est génial vous
allez voir une bonne expérience grâce à
votre prise jack et l'idée en fait ce
qu'a voulu faire
solide derrière c'est de se dire on aura
une meilleure expérience grâce à un
casque branché directement sur une prise
jack en utilisant un petit module un
petit adaptateur en usb c'est ou en
devenir perdre en qualité
et comme l'idée ici c'est vraiment de
draguer les audiophiles et bien il faut
une bonne expérience il faut la
maximiser et on peut pas aller à
l'économie donc il faut mettre une prise
jack gelé testé avec un casque sony
risque puis vous assurer que le résultat
est là ça marche bien en plus de ça vous
avez du bluetooth cinq points vous et
venir raccorder un casque sans fil
notamment le whh 1000 x n 3 de sony
je peux scène qui a un excellent casque
à réduction de bruit et qui fonctionne
parfaitement bien
est-ce qu'en plus vous avez ici le codec
ldlc qui est un codec de sony mais vous
avez aussi toute une flopée de codecs
lb c'est assez a pété xf et xj et j'en
passe et des meilleurs donc vous avez
vraiment de quoi faire entendre
l'expérience audio pur vous avez en plus
du dolby atmos du ds the ultimate le 360
en reality audio de sony on a donc une
expérience audio de vraiment bonne
qualité avec du highways avec du
highways wireless pour dire écoute avec
votre casque sans fil donc dans tous les
cas l'expérience audio est vraiment
bonne et là dessus la copie est
très bien réussi de la part de sony
alors il ya un truc que j'aime pas trop
mais ça ça avait très très très très
personnel vous retrouver ici lorsque
vous montez le son vous avez les
vibrations dynamique en récidive à son
dynamique je les ai sur youtube ce que
ça me fait c'est plus je le monte et
puis mon smartphone va vibrer et plus
jeunes baisse - vibrera si j'enlève tout
une libre plus l'idée c'est qu'il a
vibré au rythme de la musique
mais moi qui tremblent déjà des mains
j'aimerais bien éviter justement de
clôture vibrations un petit peu
nativement naturellement au niveau de
mes mains et quand on vient de le
rajouter dans un smartphone eh bien je
puis vous assurer que pour moi c'est
vraiment pas du tout du tout du tout
agréable côté fiche technique aux siens
un smartphone qui est extrêmement solide
avec la dernière puces de qualcomm last
un dragon 865 c'est une puce 5 g qui
marche très bien vous avez 8 gigas de
ram 256 go de stockage et je vous dit
tout à l'heure extensible jusqu'à
interac grâce à une carte microsd et ce
smartphone coptes assurant tout le score
de 559 1235 ce qu'il y avait classé en
neuvième position du tableau du
classement hot ceux du galaxy s 20
autres à 5 g avec un exe 1990 et en
dessous du xiaomi me disent autant dire
que fait partie des meilleurs des mieux
classés vous avez donc beaucoup de
performances vais donc un smartphone qui
va être vraiment adapté pour le gaming
est un smartphone causé une grosse
batterie de 4000 millions peyrac de la
charge rapide jamais rapide parce qu'il
est sûr de la 18 18 watts est
effectivement rapide mais c'est parce
qu'être plus rapide
on va que nouvelles technologies
aujourd'hui ont plus de 100 watts on
arrive à du 125 watts qui me permet de
recharger des vitesses absolument
incroyable il si on n'y est pas on
aurait pu espérer de la charge 25 watts
mon il faudra se contenter de 18 watts
néanmoins ça vous leur chargera de 0 à
50 % en 30 minutes
et si vous souhaitez vous avez également
de la recharge sans fil c'est un
smartphone que vous allez pouvoir
regarder entre une journée une il ya
deux jours comme si on ne fait plus de
vous de vos usages de ce que vous allez
en faire de la luminosité du nombre
d'heures auquel vous allez jouer pour la
partie ouest ont quasiment sur un
android pur presque pur vous avez
quelques fonctionnalités xperia vous
allez pouvoir venir retrouver ici aussi
intéressant c'est le double tap sur le
côté vous avez donc votre détection
d'intérêt avec différentes applications
vous allez pouvoir voir votre mode multi
fenêtres par exemple en hausse de mai
youtube en bas je le mets la
calculatrice peut venir régler ma
fenêtre
comme je veut brasser un peu pratiqué
c'est aussi l'intérêt d'avoir un
smartphone qui énonçait pouvoir faire
effectivement du multi fenêtres
je me remets dedans mode à une main si
je veux l'utiliser vraiment à une main
ya les cinéphiles il ya
audiophiles mais il ya également les
gamers en cible pour ce smartphone vous
serez pas sans savoir que le gaming est
aujourd'hui des usages qui sont répand
de plus en plus et notamment sur mobile
est ici sony a aussi une branche gaming
avec notamment playstation alors on n'a
pas une playstation dans son smartphone
mais en tout cas on peut faire des
choses et c'est plutôt bien fait vous
allez pouvoir jouer à 129 le jeu est
complètement optimisé en 21 9ème et ça
c'est vraiment très très très très bon
vous pouvez profiter également des
vibrations dynamique si vous le
souhaitez mais il ya un truc aussi qui
vraiment intéressant et malheureusement
j'en ai pas ici pourquoi vous le montrez
vous pouvez utiliser une manette de ps 4
votre smartphone est compatible manette
dualshock 4 sans fil pour plus on est un
smartphone qui est certifié snapdragon
et lidié mines ça c'est bien et vous
avez un univers gimme vous pouvez
retrouver ici avec votre mode jeu
réglage des priorités quand venir
enregistrer capturer l'écran pourrait
venir paramétrer pas mal de choses en
fonction de vous de ce que vous voulez
faire de vos besoins on n'est pas sur le
smartphone le plus optimisée pour le
gagner mais croyez-moi déjà qu'avec la
performance la puce tout ce que vous
avez derrière vous avez vraiment de quoi
faire
il nous reste encore deux univers
explorés le premier ça va être l'univers
de la photo et 2e l'univers de la vidéo
parce que oui vous le savez enfin vous
êtes peut-être pas sans savoir que sony
est très bon très présent au niveau de
la photo avec sa gamme sony alpha
autant vous dire qu'ici tout est mis en
avant et d'ailleurs je sais même pas si
vous le savez mais on trouve très
souvent des capteurs de sonic dans
différents smartphones en différentes
marques de smartphones puisque leurs
capteurs sont des références dans le
domaine
alors ici sony nous a fait un choix qui
est très intéressant très astucieux très
judicieux mais peut-être des fois un
petit peu trop alors fait donc traiter
la partie de la photo et de la vidéo
ensemble parce qu'elle fonctionne de
pair qu'on va utiliser la même partie
matérielle il ya une différence logiciel
vous avez deux applications
professionnelles vous pouvez utiliser
aussi l'application un peu standard et
vous allez voir que des choses qui sont
très bien un peu complexe il ya certains
ratés et ce smartphone en photos et en
vidéo n'est pas forcément fait pour tout
le monde on va commencer par la config
vous avez trois capteurs photo voulons
réussir vous avez un petit 4e qui est
planqué alors vous avez 3 capteur de 12
mégapixels le premier s'arrête en grand
angle en équivalent 24 mm bref un point
cette stabilisation optique vous avez un
deuxième c'est un téléobjectif
équivalent 70 mm qui ouvre à f 2.4
stylisation optique avec un zoom optique
x 3 et une stabilisation optique et puis
troisième c'est un ultra grand angle
équivalent de 16 mm ouvre à f 2.0 avec
un champ de vision de 124 degrés
si vous avez une toute petite caméra
c'est la caméra tough qui est là pour la
profondeur de champ pour notre portrait
avec pas moins de quarante 3200 points
pensée extrêmement précis tandis qu'à
l'avant vous avez une toute petite
caméra ici c'est une 8 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.0
vous voilà rendu les photos caméra
principale ultra-grand-angle
téléobjectif et tout de suite qu'on doit
noter qui est intéressant c'est qu'on va
rester dans le même espace
colorimétrique on a pas de différence
entre l'ultra grand temps que le canada
principal c'est plutôt rare et de la
même chose au niveau du téléobjectif
pour voir qu'on n'est pas du tout sur le
même objectif donc ça s'est bien rendu
qui est plutôt qualitatif quelque chose
de très naturel très neutre on va pas
être sursaturé au niveau des bleus ni au
niveau des verts ont garé du détaillant
n'est vraiment pas quelque chose qui est
vraie qui est juste qui est naturel et
c'est vraiment ce que je vais bien aimé
en tout cas sur le rendu photo qu'on va
avoir avec ce smartphone donc ça s'est
vraiment bien le truc que j'ai regretté
un petit peu c'est qu'on n'a pas de
photos en raw vous retrouverez dureau
uniquement dans une prochaine mise à
jour mais pour voir qu'on est sur une
idée professionnel avec une application
professionnelle ça je vis un petit peut
le regretter mais voyez le rendu que
vous allez avoir la qualité ça
fonctionne vraiment bien et sosa
vraiment couleur jaune en main d'ici en
auvergne pour garder un peu les paysages
nous fait voyager en même temps mado si
bien le le détail au niveau des nuages
on a les arbres devant on a aussi bien
la colline en face les éoliennes sur
tout va les enlever ce serait mieux mais
ça reste très très chouette c'est pareil
le marola est assez juste entre vraiment
ces deux types de marron avec les bouts
d'choux on a le détail également
lorsqu'on passe en ultra grand-angle
s'est pas particulièrement déformant et
ça fonctionne et on vient se rapprocher
on garde du détail avec le thé
l'objectif on l'a bien si au niveau
d'équipés où ça fonctionne il ya
vraiment une très très belle qualité qui
est fait là dessus au niveau de cet
appareil et même la caméra selphy est
bonne on va pas voir une peau qui sur
l'iss est ce qu'on retrouve souvent avec
beaucoup de smartphones est ce que je
regrette donc a vendu qui est vraiment
honnête en termes de photos il n'en fait
pas trop
comme je le disais ce qu'on va retrouver
ici ce sont deux applications
professionnelles que son photo pro pour
la photo cinéma pro et vous avez
l'application qui n'est pas
professionnel c'est l'application un peu
standard on va commencer par celle là en
premier histoire de faire un petit tour
je vous le dis tout de suite je ne
trouve pas ça très pratique je n'aime
pas particulièrement leur effectivement
on va retrouver ici ultra-grand-angle
devine très facilement on va trouver ici
la caméra le standard alkylants 24 mm et
puis si votre télé objectifs ok pourquoi
pas vous dire en plus
zoomer dans le thé l'objectif non c'est
pas réellement où est-ce qu'on en est
donc là je pars de
je sais pas exactement où j'en suis je
sais pas jusqu'à 1 combien je montre
réellement bon ça c'est pas déjà
extrêmement intuitif qui voulait
chercher vos différents modes de vie
retrouvée là vous souhaitiez dans
l'appli photo pro google dance ralenti
selphy créatif panoramique ok mais c'est
pas extrêmement intuitif pour moi qui
suis habitué à des smartphones un peu
plus standard mais les grandes lignes
mais quand je dis ça je te switcher sur
la partie vidéo ici je t'admire film et
je vois jusqu'en quatre cas mais je
trouve ça extrêmement pratiques pas très
intuitif il n'y a absolument pas de mode
nuit dans ce mode là en tout cas donc si
je vois un extérieur faire des photos la
nuit et bien j'ai pas être hyper
optimisé comme ça non si je veux aller
beaucoup plus loin et faire des belles
photos nuit il faut que j'aille dans
l'application photos pro et c'est là que
ça devient beaucoup plus complexe et que
je trouve que on se perd un peu on se
perd un peu pourquoi parce que vous avez
une application qui est extrêmement
complète mais si vous n'êtes pas un
champion de la photo et sans forcément
pareil boîtiers reflex mais si vous
n'êtes pas habitué aux appareils photo
nd chute à être un petit peu plus
compliqué parce que vous avez quand même
beaucoup de mode beaucoup de choses
pouvaient venir régler ou pas des choses
qu'on comprend tout de suite très
facilement et un autre c'est un peu plus
compliqué vous avez votre niveau qui est
là il ya pas mal de petits réglages que
pouvaient venir faire vous choisissez
votre objectif ici entre le 16 et le 24
il 70 ok pourquoi pas et puis ensuite
vous avez différents réglages entre sont
les différentes prises de vue et une
fois de plus pour venir s'amuser à
fouiller là dedans il faut avoir envie
je vais pas dire qu'il faut être un
professionnel parce que malgré tout on
reste sur un soft de smartphones mais il
faut avoir un petit peu ce cette envie
qui vous anime d'aller voir ce qui se
passe que ce soit au niveau de la photo
est encore plus haut niveau de la vidéo
où je trouve que beaucoup c'est vrai
certaines choses mais excusez moi je
suis utilisateur lambda j'achète ce
smartphone je tombe là dessus je me dis
what the fuck
qu'est ce que je vais faire alors après
je vais bidouiller je vais gratouiller
je vais finir par comprendre mais
choisir mon nom d' images par seconde la
résolution mon look un peu la
colorimétrie mon image je me dis mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça pourquoi
quelques ça va me faire choisir mon
objectif
ok pourquoi pas mon iso est ce que je
suis capable de savoir régler mon iso
facilement ou pas est ce que j'ai envie
balance des blancs c'est exactement la
même chose l'obturateur enfin tout ça
c'est bien mais c'est très complexe et
c'est là où vous voyez que votre cible
grand public et bien elle s'affine elle
sa finale safina devient beaucoup plus
petit
brou plus étroite pour devenir un
smartphone de niche ses obligations de
sony est très compliquée sur ce modèle
là puisque vous adresser aux cinéphiles
aux audiophiles au gamer aux amateurs de
photo
amateurs de vidéos pourquoi ceux qui
veulent venir créer de la vidéo
créateurs de contenu il vous retrouver
qu'une solution qui peut être bien qui
peut être très intéressante si vous avez
envie mais monsieur madame tout le monde
n'ont pas forcément envie d'aller dessus
et n'oubliez pas que l'on se retrouve
toujours sur un smartphone à 1199 euros
où vous avez enfin des acteurs qui sont
solides très solides je dis pas que sony
n'est pas solide mais cette proposition
de valeur avec délicate parce que on se
nichent énormément quand on sait que la
photo c'est un des usages les plus
courants tout le monde fait des photos
les vidéos un petit peu moins quoique de
plus en plus avec l'explosion de tik tok
der hilst d'instagram la vidéo va
s'étendre davantage donc il faut des
outils faciles
il faut du pôle tenchu qu'il faut que
vous preniez votre smartphone vous
appuyez vous filmer ces pratiques c'est
simple vous avez juste un ou deux
boutons sur lesquels appuyer
vous partagez vous mettez en ligne et ça
marche là l'idée d'avoir une usine à gaz
parce que c'est un petit peu ce que ça
devient c'est bien pour les personnes
qui sont vraiment amatrice de photos
mais pour le reste du monde voulait
permis et c'est un peu ce qui est
difficile et ce que je trouve délicat
sur un smartphone comme celui acquis via
smartphone exigeant mais qui n'est pas
du coup pour moi un smartphone destiné
plus au grand public sur un des usages
qui est plus importants notamment les
âges de la photo mais je pense que là
dessus sony a voulu aller très loin d'y
regarder
voilà ce qu'on sait faire avant là le
meilleur de nos différents univers écran
bravia oled lo'jo ce qu'on est capable
de faire avec ciné halte à ce qu'on est
capable de faire au niveau du gaming
avec l'idée de playstation avec la
compatibilité avec la manette
l'idée de ce qu'on peut faire avec sony
alpha il ya tellement de choses qu'à la
fin ce smartphone devient très complexe
très nicher et va être difficile à
vendre au grand public il ya tout un
chacun
et ça c'est un peu difficile alors
j'aurais pu comprendre effectivement
qu'est une application photo pro qui a
une application cinéma pro qui s'adresse
aux personnes qui veulent aller plus
loin mais si vous arrivez même dans
l'application qui est native alors
effectivement vous dites j'ai mon
application pro qui situent juste là
pourquoi pas mais malgré tout
l'appliquent sommes allés là pour moi
elle n'est pas extrêmement intuitive il
aurait fallu une appli plus android pur
un peu plus standard où on s'y retrouve
entre nos différents modes panorama
portrait tandis que la voilà moi je
prends ça en main j'allume je me dis où
est ce que je trouvais mode portrait ou
et montmagny se faire des photos la nuit
je veux une expo longue
où est le mot nuit et bien si je veux
faire de bonnes photos la nuit jarguel
fois de plus je vais dans mon
application et je vais venir à m'amuser
avec mon temps d'exposition s'est dit
amusé avec l'aval de paramètres mais ce
n'est pas forcément d'aujourd'hui
et ça pour moi seigneur mais après la
promesse se trouve extrêmement sexy le
fait d'avoir la reconnaissance de l'oeil
humain même d'animaux à venir ajouté
votre animal facilement 7 eye-tracking
il est vraiment super l'isi d'avoir un
autofocus très rapide de 60 fois par
seconde c'est très bien l'idée faire des
photos en rafale
vingt fois par seconde aussi on a
effectivement une maîtrise derrière une
fois de plus pour les personnes qui vont
être vraiment amatrice de photos et si
vous êtes vraiment à me tendre photo
allez-vous avoir un smartphone pour
venir faire des photos même si la partie
software est cool ou alors allez vous
avoir un petit boîtier que vous allez
emmener avec vous pour pouvoir tenir
ajouté vous faire plaisir
that is the sun d'ailleurs si vous
faites de la photo peut être que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire le sony
xperia one mark ii est un smartphone qui
a dû à un excès ça c'est bien
du wifi si ce que vous allez voir venir
utiliser avec votre sony alpha rope en
le mettant sur une saison comme un petit
moniteur pratique et qui a un das je
vous le dis je n'ai pas appris par coeur
daste est de 1,12 le watt par kilogramme
un das tronc de 0.67 watts par
kilogramme et un das membres de 2,79
watts par kilogramme
la question est et vous allez ça magique
pour y répondre
est-ce qu'il faut acheter ce smartphone
est ce qu'il vaut le coup est ce qu'il
est intéressant alors juste toujours un
peu mitigé parce que plus on va ni chez
un produit plus on à s'adresser à une
cible qui est très très très très fine
vous en douterez plus vous ni chez moi
vous avez de clients potentiels en face
à une fête plus est on un tarif qui est
quand même un peu élevé
1199 euros et à 1199 euros vous avez de
très gros acteurs avec de très belles
propositions de valeur est ce que sony
va réussir à tirer son épingle du jeu
j'ai du mal à y croire
pas parce que les textes ne sont pas
bonnes pas parce que le produit n'est
pas drôle produite intéressant le format
est intéressant l'écran est de bonne
qualité
la proposition globale et bien l'audio
une bonne qualité aux smartphones qui
est extrêmement puissant et comme
beaucoup de smartphones je dirais dans
cette gamme de prix
néanmoins il va souffrir un peu par là
le format un peu trop allongé et encore
même si j'ai un grand bémol là dessus
pour moi usage de plus dur va être
lusage de la photo et de la vidéo je
vous dis une fois de plus même si la
vidéo
quelque chose qui se développe mais qui
n'est pas encore complètement
extrêmement développé d'un point de vue
grand public mais la partie photo c'est
sûr c'est extrêmement important
comment voulez vous qu'avec une
application qui est aussi pointue on
puisse draguer tout le grand public moi
j'ai vraiment du mal à y croire et je
trouve ça dommage je continue a trouvé
ça intéressant ce que tu as trouvé la
proposition de valeur intéressante le
fait que sony réfléchisse à ce qu'ils
savent faire de mieux dans leurs
différentes divisions
pour capter une clientèle un peu plus
large pour moi c'est un beauf actif
c'est une très belle vitrine mais je
suis pas persuadé que sony en vend
d'énormément de par ce côté un peu trop
- tu peut-être faudrait-il un smartphone
qui gardent l'adn de sony alpha en étant
moins pointu peut-être faut-il aller
chercher un peu ce que font les autres
un écran 120 air souvent 90,1 paraître
le grand minimum une fois de plus à 1199
euros
il ya une réflexion à mener là dessus je
pense qu'il faut aller dans ce sens là
pour que sony réussisse enfin avec un
excellent ce matin comme celui-là a
capté le coeur du grand public à vous me
direz vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
l'acheter ce sony xperia one mark ii est
ce que vous avez déjà acheté le mark 1
est ce que vous avez acheté le sony
xperia 10 est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
un smartphone de sony et si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter mark et moi tout ça en bas on
commentaires dites moi vous ce que vous
en pensez
quant à notre trouve extrêmement
rapidement parce que plein de choses à
se dire la tête n'arrive pas et même en
été nous doit beaucoup d'amour a très
vite ciao
[Musique]